so I actually so I actually have no kill
you papi hey guys i'm abby Sharpe
welcome to Abby's kitchen and this is
our brand new series things worth the
splurge so today we're going to talk
about my top 5 things that are worth the
splurge in those first few months
postpartum for mom so my first thing is
a night nanny or postpartum doula now I
know this sounds like a total luxury and
it is again this is worth the splurge
but sometimes your sanity is worth
saving for because those first few days
after you get home from the hospital
especially if had a really rough labor
and delivery are so exhausting to have a
little bit of night sport can mean the
difference between you know a really
difficult long recovery and actually
getting back on your feet fast so
basically what a night nanny or a night
nurse does is they are responsible for
helping with feeding and burping and
diapering and some baby laundry and
washing bottles or pumps and as well as
some breastfeeding support all
throughout the night and if you're
breastfeeding you're still gonna need to
get up several times in the night to
actually do the breastfeeding and the
pumping or whatever you might be doing
however it's gonna save you a lot of
time because you're not gonna have to do
the whole routine before and after and
trying to get baby back to sleep or
change him and burp him so that's gonna
get you back into bed much faster so
that you can actually recover and you
know get to the the next day in one
piece now the role of the postpartum
doula differs in that they actually are
more focused on taking care of mom so
that you of course as a mom can do a
better job taking care of baby coz
you're gonna
a little bit more well-rested and a
little bit more supported so whichever
one you kind of feel like is going to be
more helpful to you or daytime or more
nighttime support more focused on the
baby more focused on you as the mom both
of these services are an absolute
lifesaver especially in those first few
days so if you have some friends and
family who are asking you what can I get
you postpartum definitely ask to chip in
to the night nanny or the postpartum
doula fund because I think you're gonna
find that a lot more effective and a lot
more useful than just like a bunch of
onesies and receiving blankets so number
two is pelvic floor physiotherapy so
even if you have a c-section a lot
changes when it comes to the lady flower
after giving birth let me tell you for
the first few days after I gave birth I
literally had to hold my crotch every
single time I would stand up so that I
wouldn't pee myself
I mean I still can't really jump or when
I go downhill after got to be really
careful that I don't have a full bladder
or else you know things are gonna be
coming out so pelvic floor therapy is
really really important because it helps
you learn proper kegels it helps you
find the ways to sit or stand event
incontinence it can also help diagnose
and repair prolapse or diastasis recti
which is the separation of the abdominal
muscles and a session is basically like
vagina Pilates which is kind of
uncomfortable especially if you're a
little bit sore down there but honestly
it is essential in my books for
long-term relief so definitely
definitely definitely check that out
get yourself a few sessions or ask a
friend or fan
to contribute to that as a nice gift all
right number three the EPI no we need
like that sound effect with like the
Rays of Sun coming out of this because
this literally saved my vagina alright
so I'm gonna show you what this is I
actually recommend that you guys get
this before you give birth but
definitely has some serious benefits
after birth as well so basically and I
promise I wash this I wash this
thoroughly before we shot this today it
is like a balloon and you just tighten
this for a second and you pump up this
balloon and you insert it into your
vagina and then you pump this up just
into the opening of your jaw vagina and
you try to get as big as you can every
single night you just hold it in there
for as long as you can 15 minutes or so
and then you pull it out and then you
measure it on this template here and you
can see you know how many centimeters
you got that night you know it's a
little game you can play with yourself
before you give birth and I did this
every single night since about 34 weeks
and by the end leave it or not well I
don't know if I'm gonna get that far
right now but I was able to get it past
ten seven years
I know I don't know what that says about
me but let me tell you what it says
about me I gave birth I did not tear at
all and I did not need a single stitch
which might o be told me is very very
rare for first-time moms so I felt very
proud so yeah this is probably about
nope that's not even ten sinning years
so I still got bigger than this cuz the
baby's head is you know pretty big has
to get out of you and then after you
give birth you can use this as
biofeedback to improve those keegels
that your pelvic floor physiotherapist
gave you because you can measure the
pressure that you're exerting on the on
the balloon and that kind of you can
measure this on the pressure gauge here
so yes it's $200 but I would say my
vagina is worth that and you know my
partner would probably agree with me on
that and for all you ladies out there
who are looking at this and thinking hey
maybe I can DIY that I don't recommend
you going to the craft supply store and
picking up a regular latex balloon and
going to town with it get the
professional version it is worth the
money number four a lactation consultant
so before I gave birth I was trying to
be really proactive and I asked all my
mommy support groups for some names of
great lactation consultants and I made
like a whole list and by the time I got
home from the hospital I was already so
exhausted and sore and frustrated with
the whole breastfeeding struggle that I
was going through that I just went down
the list and called them all and and I
hired the first one that picked up
literally I just was so desperate I
needed them to come over that very
moment and I'm so glad that I did
honestly even if I wasn't struggling
with breastfeeding from the beginning I
think it was a really good idea to get
someone into
valuate the situation because you want
to make sure that you're not having a
bad latch because once you get into a
bad latch groove you know it's like a
vicious cycle where you you're
breastfeeding pants a lot more painful
you'll have a lot more anxiety around
breastfeeding you don't want to do it
you know and that just kind of goes on
and goes on it goes on and it's best to
just nip it in the bud from the get-go
so a lactation consultant can help with
latching issues low supply problems
painful nursing they can also help
diagnose a lip and tongue tie both of
which my son had so I'm really happy
that I had some look at that ASAP and we
had it dealt with immediately or else
you know I could still be really
struggling with breastfeeding so that's
something that I'm really really
grateful for that I had in the bag from
the get-go and finally a double electric
breast pump so this might not be
essential for all moms depending on you
know if they just don't want to
breastfeed or if they want to
exclusively breastfeed however I do
think it's good to be prepared from when
life throws you lemons case in point
my story so I was not able to breastfeed
because my kid had I lived in a Tong
time it was pretty severe so he would
not watch and I was so grateful that I
had breast pump at home waiting for me
to help to boost my supply otherwise I
could have missed out on a really
important opportunity to get my milk
flowing and get things moving along I
remember when I was in the hospital the
other couple that we were sharing our
hospital room with we're talking to the
lactation consultant there and they were
told that they had to get a friend to
buy them a breast pump immediately
because she had really flattened apples
and was unable to get a good latch and
really want to get that milk production
stimulated so even if you do plan to
exclusively breastfeed and you're having
no struggles at all you might want to
have a breast pump at home to help to
boost that supply so you can get going a
little bit faster so you can get to
exclusive breastfeeding so I prefer the
double electric version not the arcade
manual version because one time I had to
use the manual and I want to die because
it's just my hand was like cramping by
the end just trying to get enough milk
out of each breast I actually have a
second breast pump because my kid has
been about 80 percent pumped breast milk
and the rest breastfed as a working mom
that's kind of really important to me so
just in case anything goes wrong or my
pump goes down I have a backup so guys I
hope you are enjoying this new series
here if you loved this video be sure to
give the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with some of your absolute
essentials worth the splurge products or
services for new moms postpartum
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]